folks as you all know daytime talk shows
are probably the biggest thing going
right now everybody's getting one
everyone's talking about him and I'm
very excited to announce that our own
Andy Richter has entered the ring and
you want to tell us about it well I like
you said there's all these daytime talk
shows and I you know I watch most of
them and I think if these people can get
one I ought to get one you know you just
missed Election Day you could have voted
for me um just kidding
but it's I thought you know and
especially because I work at a
television studio yeah it's it's empty
most of the day yeah right most of the
time you know I just come down here and
nap on the couch I figured why not
actually use it you know excellent idea
and and you know you ahead went ahead
and let me so yeah no problem I thought
it was a great idea yes all right well
you're excited about this thing it's
going well it yeah it's going great
all right well let's take a look yes
this is a clip from the first
installment right of Andy simply called
and simply called Andy ladies and
gentlemen enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
hi thank you very much thanks folks my
first guests tonight are two of these
stars of late night on NBC
please welcome Conan O'Brien and Max
Weinberg
[Music]
thanks for coming gentlemen welcome well
let's get right to it now Conan you've
been harboring a huge grudge against max
and and you've decided to tell him about
it right here on the Andy show right I'm
talking about you know max did something
in your dressing room go ahead tell him
let him have it with both barrels right
here on the Andy show yeah tell me Andy
remember
Conan last week before the show max went
into your dressing room and ate all the
strawberries off your fruit plate
remember what you said to me when he
left look Andy I'm trying to do you a
favor by appearing on your stupid show
all right what do you think you're doing
what is this hey audience sounds like
Conan's got a classic case of the self
denial Tamar right yeah on the Andy show
the self-denials are no no no Maxo
hopefully you can be a little more
honest than your friend Conan here now
isn't it true that you took a little
walk on the wild side back in your
swingin college days what do you
remember this voice max I think you will
we were both drunk in my dorm room
after studying half the night well I've
never regretted what we did even after
all these years let's go oh yeah hot
stuff wait where you going I don't well
I'd offer to pay for counseling for max
and Conan but I don't think it'll help
we'll be right back
[Music]
I think it looks great show you got yeah
just there to help and I understand will
be having us some more installments as
Yanks go on that's right we've got a lot
more stuff some of it even better than
that I can't imagine it congratulations
Andy folks we'll be right back with
Ivana Trump stick around